bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va les des cartes au lait
écartelé
bien née en 1948 il s'est fait connaître
en 1997 avec la publication de son livre
le pouvoir du moment présent
un best-seller mondial traduit dans 33
langues
si ce livre a eu autant de succès à
travers le monde cela tient probablement
à deux raisons
la première raison étant sa grande
accessibilité
c'est un livre qui se lit très
facilement
et la deuxième raison tient sans doute
au sujet même du livre et à sa promesse
qui est de nous expliquer comment
accéder immédiatement au bonheur
alors bien entendu quand on entend ça on
est en droit d'être un peu sceptique on
est en droit d'être un peu sceptique
parce que des livres qui nous promettent
de nous donner la clé du bonheur il y en
a un paquet
et ne sachant pas que ces livres est
effectivement rendu l'humanité plus
heureuse
pour autant est-ce que ça veut dire que
le livre des cartes au lait n'a rien à
nous apprendre
eh bien en l'occurrence se livrent à des
choses à nous apprendre
j'ai bien con en ce que pour beaucoup
parler d'un livre qui a pour titre le
pouvoir du moment présent c'est
suffisant pour andy se qualifier le
contenu par avance
c'est suffisant pour se dire qu'on va
encore avoir à faire un énième livres de
développement personnel ou de
spiritualité bon marché
et bien ce que je tentez de vous montrer
aujourd'hui c'est que les choses ne sont
pas aussi simples qu'elles en ont l'air
et qu'au delà de l'aspect recette du
bonheur on trouve dans le pouvoir du
moment présent une véritable proposition
philosophique proposition philosophique
que nous allons explorer et analysés
durant cet épisode
alors sur
fyk écart tollé a grandi en allemagne il
part vivre en angleterre où il devient
professeur d'allemand et d'espagnol et
alors qu'il souffrait d'une dépression à
l'âge de 29 ans il va vivre une
expérience mystique
ils sortent de nuit de feu pascal yens
à l'issue de laquelle il prend
conscience ce sont ces mots de la
perfection du monde et de l'illusion du
temps
des cartes au lait va encore plus loin
puisqu'il comprend d'où vient la
souffrance de l'homme moderne car selon
lui si nous souffrons ce n'est pas en
raison de nos conditions de vie ce n'est
pas en raison de notre situation
matérielle objective
de notre tendance à nous infliger nous
mêmes de la souffrance
une souffrance qui l'appelle
france mental
et la thèse d'écarteler c'est que cette
tal nous avons le goût voire d'y mettre
un terme
alors avant d'en arriver là avant d'en
arriver aux moyens de mettre un terme à
cette souffrance explique ont un peu ce
qu'est carto les nomme la souffrance
mentale
la souffrance mentale c'est notre
tendance on pourrait même dire notre
besoin de penser à des choses qui nous
font sortir du moment présent
c'est le fait d'être en train de faire
quelque chose et de penser à des choses
qui n'ont aucun rapport c'est à dire à
des choses qui n'ont pas d'utilité ni de
pertinence dans la situation présente
donc on va prendre quelques exemples
prendre tout ça un peu concret par
exemple vous êtes en train de prendre
votre petit déjeuner et vous pensé au
fait que vous devez appeler votre
banquier que vous devez passer récupérer
un colis à la poste que vous devez
acheter du café
vous êtes en train de conduire et vous
pensez au travail
pensez à la discussion vous devez avoir
avec votre patron à sa réaction quand
vous allez lui demander une semaine de
congé bref vous attend quelque chose
vous êtes physiquement occupé à quelque
chose
ses ailes sont ailleurs
c'est quelque chose qu'on nous
on est en train de
ir de travailler ou même de parler avec
des amis et tout à coup on pense à autre
chose
à des choses sans rapport avec la
situation présente
est ce que remarque écartelé c'est que
ces pensées qui occupent notre esprit à
chaque instant on ne parvient pas à les
arrêter
on parvient pas à maîtriser le flux de
nos pensées
elles s'introduisent dans notre esprit
pour ainsi dire sens y avoir été invité
et une pensée succédant à une autre
notre esprit se retrouvent saturé de
penser
notre esprit devient un vacarme
incessant de penser
autrement dit le problème attends que
notre esprit soit occupé par des pensées
le problème est que ces pensées prennent
un caractère compulsif
car impulsif c'est-à-dire à caractère
non maîtrisables
triste pas le flux des pensées qui nous
traversent
et ça c'est problématique
c'est problématique parce que ne pas
vous
cette pensée être sous l'emprise de la
pensée c'est ne plus être libre
epictète disait qu être sous l'emprise
de ses émotions c'était en être
l'esclave
est bien de la même façon écartelé
considère qu'être sous l'emprise de ses
pensées c'est être l'esclave de son
mental
et c'est pour ça les voix dans la pensée
compulsive quelque chose de l'ordre de
la pathologie
ce de pathos
c'est la souffrance
le temps
bi
bon souffrir c'est subir
la pensée compulsive est une souffrance
parce qu'elle fait de notre esprit un
territoire occupé
avons perdu le contrôle
et si la pensée compulsive est une
souffrance c'est aussi parce qu'elle est
une dispersion de notre énergie
intentionnel
donc une dispersion de notre énergie
tout court
ça épuise de penser tout le temps
ça compte
donc c'est ça pour écartelé le mal
moderne cette pensée compulsive qui ne
nous laisse jamais en repos et le fait
est que nous sommes une grande majorité
avoir fait la pensée compulsive notre
état ordinaire
notre état permanent
si l'ap suite je vous demande de ne
penser à rien de faire le vide mental
vous allez voir à quel point c'est
difficile
alors que la demande et on peut plus
simple ne pensais à rien
donc ce qui est facile et difficile à
l'être humain
ne penser à rien beaucoup
même que c'est impossible
allemand impossible
qu'on a toujours quelque chose en tête
eh bien on va voir que si il est
possible de faire taire le bruit mentale
à l'intérieur de nous
mais avant ça il faut que je précise
quelque chose d'extrêmement important à
propos de la pensée compulsive sinon
quoi on risquerait de faire avec car
tollé un mauvais procès
ce que dit eckhart olé ce n'est pas un
penser
il ne nous dit pas que la pensée est un
problème
ce qu'il nous dit c'est que le besoin de
penser est un problème
c'est que l'addiction à la pensée est un
problème
à moins d'aimer vivre dans une prison
mentale
écartelé nadine la pensée
l'outil
offre un outil ce défi par son utilité
outils utiles ces mêmes mots
en quoi réside l'utilité de la pensée
elle réside dans la compréhension
on pense pour comprendre
comprendre pour connaître pour prendre
une décision bref on pense pour résoudre
pour qu'il y ai pensé il faut qu'il y
ait quelque chose à résoudre
pensez compulsive n'est pas motivée par
la résolution
elle est même motivé par l'absence de
résolution
elle est motivée par sa propre
conservation
elle est motivée par sa perpétuation
comme pensée
ça c'est la raison pour laquelle le
mental aime créer des problèmes
parce qu'ils sont nourris
a besoin d'être occupés par des
problèmes
remarqué que quand je dis aux qpc dans
les deux sens du terme
occupé au sens d'avoir pris possession
mais aussi occupé au sens de divertir
la pensée compulsive n'a pas pour but de
nous aider à résoudre des problèmes la
pensée compulsive a pour seul et unique
but de combler notre besoin de ressasser
et de nous triturer l'esprit
choses inutiles
on aime remuer notre marmite mental
on aime tellement ça que lorsque nous
donne la solution au problème on reste
focalisé sur le problème
on tient à notre problème
on existe à travers lui
en se plaignant d'un problème on se crée
une occasion de remplir le vide mentale
parce que ce vide nous effraie
pour elle est
ce une solution au problème et apporter
il faudra relancer le problème
oui mais
oui mais ça veut dire rires
merci pour la souris son nom
huchon
cherche seulement à faire exister mon
problème
ça peut sembler une façon un peu
expéditive de formuler les choses mais
on fait tous l'expérience de cette
pensée compulsive dans laquelle on se
complaît est laquelle on veut absolument
donner une justification
on dira que la pensée a toujours une
utilité effectivement à penser a
toujours une utilité
ne serait ce que pour le plaisir de la
gymnastique intellectuelle
mais il n'empêche que si vous n'êtes pas
en capacité
d'interrompre vos pensées
les interrompre pendant un intervalle de
dix secondes
et vous pouvez faire l'essai en mettant
cet épisode en pose
est bien c'est que talent n'est plus
votre instrument mais que vous êtes
devenu l'instrument de votre mental
vous n'êtes plus sujet de la pensée vous
êtes devenu l'objet de la pensée
elle devenue esclave du mental
je cite
l'incapacité à s'arrêter c est une
épouvantable affliction nous ne nous en
rendons pas compte parce que presque
tout le monde en est atteint nous en
venons à la considérer comme normal cet
incessant bruit mental vous empêche de
trouver ce royaume de calme intérieur
qui est indissociable de l'être
l'identification au mental créé chez
vous un écran opaque de concepts
d'étiquettes d'image deux mots de
jugement et de définition qui empêche
toute vraie relation cet écran
s'interpose entre vous et vous même
entre vous et votre prochain entre vous
et la nature entre vous et le divin
c'est cet écran de pensée qui amène
cette illusion de division illusion qu
il y avoue et un autre totalement
séparée de vous le mental est un
magnifique outil si l'on s'en sert à bon
escient dans le cas contraire il devient
très destructeur plus précisément ce
n'est pas tant que vous utilisez mal
votre mental c'est plutôt qu'en général
vous ne vous en servez pas du tout car
c'est lui qui se sert de vous et c'est
cela la maladie puisque vous croyez être
votre mental c'est cela l'illusion
l'outil a pris possession de vous
la différence entre pensez compulsive et
la pensée maîtriser c'est que la pensée
compulsive et non seulement involontaire
elle est également décorrélé de la
situation que vous êtes en train de
vivre
la pensée compulsive c'est une et
cumulatives
sans contact avec la réalité présente
et qui surtout n'a pas intérêt à être en
contact avec la réalité présente parce
que le moindre contact avec cette
réalité là ferait éclater
al'inverse la pensée maîtrisé a une
utilité
elle a une pertinence parce qu'elle est
en contact avec la réalité présente
quand vous hissé à l'endroit vous avez
posé vos clés parce que vous en avez
besoin pour fermer la porte derrière
vous c'est utile
votre pensée est corrélée à la réalité
en revanche penser au moment où vous
avez passé avec telle personne qui n'est
plus là où penser au fait que vous avez
un examen à passer dans une semaine ou
quinze jours vous allez mourir ce n'est
pas utile
utile tout simplement parce que votre
pensée n'apporte aucun élément dont vous
ne disposiez pas déjà avant d'y penser
ça répond seulement un besoin de penser
un besoin incontrôlable
pensez à l'une de nos expériences
passées dans laquelle on a vu commis une
erreur pour ne pas reproduire cette
erreur dans le présent
c'est utile
mais repenser sempiternel mans à cette
erreur se rejouer à 2 nauseam le film de
nos erreurs c'était plus de la pensée
c'est du masochisme pour
prendre une analogie on admet que le
fait de ne pas pouvoir se retenir de
manger le fait d'être sous l'emprise
d'un besoin de manger c'est un problème
appelle ça l'hyperphagie ou la boulimie
c'est un trouble du
terme
mais le fait de ne pas vous se retenir
de penser est ce que ce n'est pas
également problématique
en termes de biens être et de santé
psychologique
parce que dans les faits la pensée qu'on
civ c'est une boulimie mental
lippert coe j on le besoin irrépressible
de créer des scénarios manteau de penser
inlassablement à des choses sur
lesquelles on n'a aucune prise
sur lesquels on ne veut pas en avoir
c'est de la boulimie mentale
la différence ce set
j'ai à cette boulimie mentale
et donc si on veut sidéré la pensée
compulsive comme un trouble il faudrait
alors reconnaître que nous sommes tous
malades
c'est un peu coûteux
donc je le répète dernière fois parce
que je sais qu'on s'approche souvent à
cet argument qui n'en est pas un il ne
s'agit pas de dire que le mental est
foncièrement mauvais ou même qu'il est
inutile
il s'agit de dire que le mental est un
formidable outil lorsqu'il s'agit de
résoudre des problèmes mais qu'il
devient notre bourreau dès lors qu'ils
échappent à notre contrôle
on peut pas
et de faire le lien avec mythe de
prométhée
le don du feu aux hommes
représente la connaissance du représente
la pensée et lorsque le feu est maîtrisé
m l'homme est armé face au monde
il peut créer les outils il peut se
chauffer s'éclairer
et quand le feu n'est plus maîtrisée
celle incendie
la connaissance fonte de façon similaire
elle est notre outil de survie
instruments de notre élévation mais non
maîtrisée et sur la bombe
bon sur l'auto on
le fait que le mental
la principale source de souffrance chez
l'être humain ne vient pas seulement du
fait que la pensée compulsive échappent
à notre contrôle
cela vient aussi du fait que la pensée
compulsive correspond à ce que les
stoïciens appelait une agitation de
l'âme
alors analysons un peu ça
en français l'euro au delà c'est ce
qu'on appelle la quiétude deux
là qui est qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs
dans le mot anglais wiotte c'est le
calme intérieur
c'est lorsque notre esprit néo perturbé
par aucune émotion ni aucune pensée
parasite
et à l' inverse
l'agitation de l'âme c'est l'inquiétude
lac tant la préoccupation mentale
sky de guerre rappelait le ce
et pourquoi ce lien entre pensée
compulsive et inquiétude est il
révélateur parce qu'il met en relief le
fait que le mental se nourrit de
scénario pessimiste
que plus on est soumis à la logique du
mental
autrement dit plus on est sous l'emprise
de la pensée compulsive plus on
hébergera en ou de l'inquiétude
quand vous
est en retard et qui n'auraient vos
messages vous allez avoir
hurel à vous inquiéter
à vous inquiéter à dire à imaginer pire
à imaginer scénario pessimiste
il a peut-être
sinon
ou alors il est avec une autre am
ou alors il la rencontre
non il est parti avec elle
yooz quand on est inquiet
c'est un peu le principe de tu deux
inquiétudes
sion de négativité
c'est la passion qui nous porte à hyper
trop fier la probabilité d'un scénario
négatif
et là où ça pose problème c'est que le
fait de penser à des scénarios négatifs
va nécessairement produire en nous un
sentiment négatif
le sentiment associés aux scénarios
négatifs
donc pour le dire clairement quand on
pense à un malheur rend ce malheur réel
on le rend réel en nous
qu'est-ce qu'il se passe quand vous
pensez à quelque chose qui vous énerve
vous vous énervez
et quand vous vous énervez vous vous
infligez de la souffrance
souffrance qui au passage ne changera
rien à la situation qui vous énerve
pensez aux conducteurs qui vous a grillé
la priorité sur la route ça changera
rien au fait qui vous a grillé la
priorité
ça ne fera que prolonger votre
énervement dans le présent
en d'autres termes la pensée négative
créer une réalité négative qui est la
réalité de l'émotion
donc en créant de la pensée négative
vous créer de la souffrance parce que
vous créer de l'émotion négative
il y a du style c'est dans cette vision
l'idée que les émotions sont des flèches
tourner vers soi
on est la première cible de ses émotions
être en colère avoir peur
été
c'est une souffrance qu'on s'inflige
d'abord à soi-même
avant de là jose autres
c'est pour ça que c'est très important
de garder à l'esprit que quand on parle
de souffrance mentale on parle d'une
souffrance dont les effets sont très
réels
vous savez c'est la fameuse phrase qui
dit ça n'existe pas c'est dans ta tête
oui sauf que si c'est dans ma tête c'est
dans mon corps
jst
la tête sa régie un peu tout le reste
le circuit mentale pouvait tourner
indépendamment du circuit émotionnel et
corporelle n'y aurait pas de problème
mais ça marche pas comme ça
le psychologique influe sur le
physiologique
le stress anxiété la dette sion ce n'est
pas juste dans la tête
à voir boule au ventre ça va dire ce que
ça veut dire
donc la deuxième raison pour laquelle à
penser compulsive créer de la souffrance
mentale outre son caractère
incontrôlable
son caractère anxiogène
c'est le fait qu'elle projette
constamment sur la réalité une ombre de
mélodrame et de négativité
à penser compulsive c'est ce qui fait de
nous des éternels inquiet
maintenant
andres comment il est possible de sortir
de la pensée compulsive de mettre fin à
l'incessant bruit mental
il y a une dernière chose dont il faut
tenir compte
c'est le fait que nos projections
mentales se font quasiment toujours dans
deux directions temporel
le passé et le futur
on repense passé qui n'est plus où on
imagine le futur qui n'est pas encore
examinez vos propres pensées et
constater à quel point il vous arrive
souvent de repenser au passé et
d'imaginer l'avenir
la projection dans le c'est ça porte un
nom c'est le souvenir
le souvenir
même que la réécriture au présent des
expériences passées
et donc est ce qu'il se passe lorsque
vous vous souvenez
ce basque que vous rapatriez mentalement
votre passé dans votre présent
vous remplissez votre présent de votre
passé
ansa vous produisez un phénomène qui est
la dissociation mental
la dissociation mental c'est la création
d'un mois virtuel qui occupe l'esprit du
mois réel
le mois réel étant le mois présent
c'est à vos échecs ça les robes c'est
aux choses que vous regrettez
vous allez repenser à ce que serait
devenu votre vie si vous aviez agit
comme si plutôt que comme ça bref vous
allez ressasser
et ressasser ça veut dire importer dans
le présent l'émotion et l'énergie du
passé
vous rendez présente les motions issues
de vos regrets de vos peurs ou de vos
échecs
c'est ça le souvenir
c'est la scission de votre mois en deux
mois un mois présent et un mois passé
qui fait que le mois présent est présent
physiquement mais pas mentalement tandis
que le mois passé est passé physiquement
mais présent dans talent
dont votre et dissociées
même chose pour le futur
la projection dans le tueur c'est le
fait d'être déjà installé mentalement
dans une situation qui n'est pas encore
physiquement présente
la projection dans le futur c'est par
exemple la dette du dimanche soir
la déprime issus de la conscience que
vous allez bientôt devoir reprendre le
travail
autrement dit issue de la projection
d'une situation désagréable à venir
vous remarquez quand on rejoint ce qu'on
disait précédemment à savoir que quand
on se projette mentalement dans une
situation la pensée cette situation
devient réel de par l'émotion qu'elle
génère
parce qu on est bien d'accord que penser
à une situation ne rend pas cette
situation réelle
oui mais sauf que quand on pense à une
situation ont déclenché une réaction
émotionnelle liée à la projection dans
cette situation
donc on fait de cette situation une
réalité présente
est donc là encore le mois se retrouve
divisé entre deux réalités la réalité
présente qu'on habite physiquement et
pas mentalement et une réalité passé au
futur qu'on habite mentalement à défaut
de pouvoir la [ __ ] et physiquement
dans les deux cas projection c'est au
projection dans le futur
mais divisés
dans les deux cas on sort de soin
c'est ça être dissociés
c'est vivre dans ces bons c
est vivre dans ses pensées
c'est vivre en dehors soit
car c'est passé à côté de tout ce que le
présent nous présente
un mot quand même pour dire que car
tollé n'oublie pas de prendre en compte
le fait que la pensée issus de la peur
peut parfois être très utile
la peur c'est un message
un message alerte qui nous avertit d'une
menace
et ne pas tenir ce message c'est à l'eau
devant de quelques déconvenues
s'il n'avait pas
et par une voiture est-ce que je
regarderai à droite et à gauche avant de
traverser
probablement pas
c'est bien l'anticipation d'un danger
futur qui me pousse à être prudents
ou nez sauf que là on est dans le cas de
ceux dont on parlait tout à l'heure à
savoir une pensée utile
on est dans le cas d'une pensée
pertinente par rapport à la situation
présente
écartelé ne dis pas qu'il ne faut pas
anticiper ce serait idiot il nous dit
qu'il faut anticiper quand
l'anticipation a une utilité et une
pertinence
quand homo sapiens se faisait des
réserves de nourriture pour anticiper
l'hiver sa peur de manquer été utile
sapeurs étaient un message pour lui dire
qu'il fallait accumuler des réserves
mais une fois que la peur a joué son
rôle de messages
une fois qu'elle a joué son rôle
d'information
elle n'a aucune raison de rester
parce que sinon on passe sa vie à avoir
peur d'eux pourrait arriver
passe sa vie redouter un danger au lieu
de tout simplement s'y préparer tout en
gardant à l'esprit que certains dangers
sont impossibles à prévoir
et qu'en règle générale
face à un danger immédiat
sénat vie qui prend le relais
la plupart de nos émotions ne
proviennent pas de ce qui est
la plupart de nos émotions
proviennent de ce qu'on imagine pouvoir
être
retrouve ici l'idée stoïcienne selon
laquelle ce qui trouble les hommes
ce ne sont pas les choses mais les
jugements qu'ils projettent sur les
choses
pour être re il n'y a pas besoin d'être
pauvre malade on se le monde
il suffit de penser pierre
et s'il suffit de penser au pire pour
être malheureux
écartelé nous dit qu'il suffit de
s'abandonner au moment présent pour
trouver la clé du bonheur
c'est ce qu'il appelle
remplacer la pensée par la présence
la présence
c'est quelque chose
mental a du mal à comprendre
parce que c'est quelque chose qu'on ne
peut pas vraiment conceptualiser
être présent ça signifie tout simplement
que toute votre attention est concentrée
sur ce qui est en train d'être
être présent ça signifie qu'aucune
penser qu'aucune activité mentale ne
vient troubler votre expérience de ce
qui est
alors dit comme ça ça peut un peu creux
pas troubler notre expérience de ce qui
est
que
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
concrètement notre expérience de ce qui
est
c'est pas évident
alors plutôt que d'essayer de vous
l'expliqué pas 7 parce que le concept
c'est l'outil du mental or le mental
n'est pas accabler pour comprendre le
moment présent je vais vous proposer une
petite expérience de pensée
imaginez que vous êtes face à un écran
un écran noir
cet écran se déplace un point blanc
imaginait le point blanc ils se
déplacent
et le but du jeu ça va être de lever la
main aussitôt que le point blanc aura
disparu de l'écran
donc si vous n'êtes pas consentante et
sur le point si vous pensez à autre
chose ou que vous vous laisser distraire
vous n'allez pas être réactif
pour être réactif il faut que votre
attention soit tout entière focaliser
sur ce point
son ne fassent qu'un avec ce point
donc allons-y imagine écran imaginez le
point blanc qui se déplacent
vous le suivez des yeux
il rebondit quand il touche le bord de
l'écran
il continue à se déplacer
ne quittait pas des yeux
et maintenant le point
disparaît
maintenant que le point blanc a disparu
je vais vous poser une question
à part ce point à quoi d'autre avez-vous
c
trajectoire
si vous étiez pleinement concentrés sur
le point l'arrêt simple à rien
vous n'avez pas 1 parce que toute votre
attention était accaparée par ce point
parce que vous ne faisait qu'un avec
votre perception
si vous ne faisiez camp avec votre
perception
sassi vous ne faisiez camp avec le
moment présent
se connecter au moment présent s'est
concentré
long sur ce qui est
c'est ça la présence
l'investissement intégrale de notre
attention à ce qui est
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que quand on
vit une expérience intense en termes de
sensations on ne pense à rien
pense à rien d'autre qu'à ce qu'on est
en train de vivre
on ce même pas au temps qui s'écoule
et donc vivre dans le moment on sait
trop mais chaque instant en occasions
d'être attentif
ces transes mais chaque 6 sion en
spectacle ans auriel
parce que chaque instant regorge de vie
regorge de mouvements
regorge d'être
à chaque fois que vous posez votre
regard sur le monde vous posez votre
regard sur le monde en train d'être
et ces lettres lui m qui apparaît sous
vos yeux
être connecté au moment présent ça veut
dire que dès qu'on prend le temps
d'observer le monde
temps d'être attentif au moindre détail
qui composent notre expérience
pour peu qu'on investisse toute notre
puissance de concentration ce qui est en
train d'être on oublie le temps et on
oublie de penser
on est concentré moment présent le bruit
mentale cesse de lui même
parce que notre attention ne peut pas
être totalement ici et en même temps
ailleurs
si la tension
présent et total
attention au reste est égal à zéro
on disait tout à l'heure que sous
l'emprise du mental lettre ah et
dissociées
c'est entre son nom à réels et sont
moins virtuel
inverse dans la présence dans la son
exclusive au moment présent le moins
réel est aligné avec le moi virtuel
plus exactement le moi virtuel n'existe
plus
tu es l'une est temps que la projection
mentale du moins réelle si le moiré elle
est occupée par le moment présent il ne
peut plus être occupé par le passé ou
par le futur
et autant la notion de présence est une
notion difficile à saisir par le mental
autant dans la pratique c'est quelque
chose dont nous pouvons facilement faire
l'expérience
quand vous êtes tellement absorbés par
ce que vous êtes en train de vivre que
vous en oubliez le temps vous vivez le
moment présent
et donc l'enjeu pour sortir du mental et
accéder au moment présent à volonté
c'est de recréer l'expérience du point
blanc sur l'écran avec les choses du
quotidien
c'est de recréer en permanence les
conditions de l'attention totale à ce
qui est
de contempler votre environnement comme
s'ils se renouveler à chaque seconde
vous êtes en train de conduire
observez la route
observé
blanche
observez la voiture qui est devant vous
servez votre compteur de vitesse
pas seulement pour savoir à combien vous
rouler mais aussi pour le compte pelé
vous parlez avec 1 mais
observez le
écouté attentivement chaque mot qu'il
prononce
conte
voix
sur son
shu
sur ce que dit ses yeux
observez votre
concentrez-vous sur la sensation de
l'air qui rentre dans vos poumons
de l'air qui en sort
c'est ça le moment présent
ce n'est rien ça
la tension pleine et entière
est en train d'être
notre erreur c'est de considérer que ce
qui est vu mille fois le mérite
servez avec attention
c'est dramatique
parler du moment présent
sépare les deux cas ce dont on ne peut
pas parler
pourquoi parce qu'à chaque fois contre
du présent
fait à partir du mental
or le mans je ne peux pas
tueur du présent
quand on veut définir présent on dit que
c'est l'intermédiaire entre le passé et
l'avenir
le problème de son c'est de savoir ce
que veut dire intermédiaire
parce que si on peut définir le présent
que par opposition au passé et au futur
ça veut dire qu'on déplace le problème
tâche qu'on ne le résout
sainte au but
au du temps que c'était quelque chose
d'impossible à définir parce que la
pensée n'a accès qu'aux passé et au
futur
l'erreur de saint-augustin c'est d'avoir
écarté un peu trop rapidement une
deuxième hypothèse
cette hypothèse c'est que
seul le présent
east
seul le présent existe
ça voyez par exemple c'est une affiche
pas accepté
parce que ça entre totalement en
contradiction avec sa logique
savoir la logique de la temporalité
le mental ne peut évoluer que dans la
temporalité
passée et future
souvenirs et anticipation
ça qu'il faut bien qu'on rendre
mental a besoin du temps
or être prêt ça signifie justement
abolir le temps
signifie sortir de la logique mentale du
temps
donc
être affectés par le temps
ça ne veut évidemment pas dire que le
temps s'arrête autour de nous
mais ça veut dire qui disparaît de notre
tête
et en disparaissant de notre tête
disparaît avec lui la souffrance mentale
à chaque fois que vous avez vécu
quelques vous vous l'avez vécu au
présent
tout ce qui va vous m dans le futur ça
va aussi vous arrivez au présent
non
tout ce qu'on vit
or au présent
et même quand on peut sait on le fait
toujours à travers les yeux du présent
on reconstruit au présent le souvenir c
dir
on en parle à partir de notre situation
présente
on se construit une image de ce qui sera
et bien souvent on compte suite à quel
point tu es loin de la réalité
donc quoi face on est toujours dans le
présent
tout ce qu'on vit on le vit on non
tous
on le pense au non
la conclusion de ce qu'on vient de dire
que pour le mental
le présent n'existe pas
mais pour nous il est
soit
le mental adore créer des problèmes
il va faire un
et il ramène des problèmes
un projet jamais terminé
une dispute jamais les
il va faire
/
problème
le crédit disons
le semant
la mort
le passé et le futur sont des trésors à
problèmes
on les deux sont ils cible
les deux hors de portée
et ça s'arrange
tal
que ça le nourrit
on l'a dit le menton disparaît dans sion
au moment présent
pourquoi
parce que aucun problème n'existe au
présent
ce qui existe au présent
ce sont des
or le problème
c'est la projection d'une situer sont
donc ce qui fait que le problème est un
problème
ce n'est pas là a sion
c'est le statut de problèmes qu'on lui
accole mentalement
le problème c'est l'extrapolation d'une
situation
sous forme de projections pessimistes
qui n'apportent rien à la résolution du
problème
risquer va requérir de la prudence
on est d'accord
une situation
y'a va requérir une shu
on est toujours d'accord
mais ces situations ne vont pas rires 2
c
elles vont rires de la tour son
qu'est ce qui fait qu'il est si
difficile de vivre dans le moment
présent
le fait que nous soyons attachés à notre
mental
pourquoi sommes-nous atteint au mental
parce que nous nous identifions
lui
depuis que nous quand nous apprenons
ivre
on commence par andres à dire son prénom
puis à l'écrire
à l'école on fait des son pour se
décrire
pour parler de ce qu'on aime et de ce
qu'on n'aime pas
on sort de l'école
un métier et ce métier devient alors ce
qui nous donne socialement
vit des expériences
des expériences amoureuses
sentimentale amical
ces expériences nous forge
elle nous culte
et plus les années passent plus les
bases d'une autre vie augmente
notre cv personnel prend de l'ampleur
et c'est ça qu'on estime être
identité
notre vision l'identité c'est celle d'un
historique
c'est celle d'une salle d'archivés
que seriez-vous sans vos dons il
que seriez-vous
ces dossiers qui témoigne de vote c
q
je te dire p
vient cette conception lui
écartelé la récuse
il récuse parce que pour lui
notre et
ces lettres
et lettres nous y accédons par le moment
présent
je cite
aux yeux de lego le mans présent
n'existe quasiment pas car seul le passé
le futur lui importe ce renversement
total de la vérité reflète bien à quel
point le mental est dénaturée quand il
fonctionne sur le mode ego sa
préoccupation est de toujours maintenir
le passé en vie car sans lui qui seriez
vous ils se projettent constamment dans
le futur pour assurer sa survie et pour
y trouver une forme quelconque de
relâchement et de satisfaction il se dit
un jour quand ceci ou cela se produira
je serais bien heureux en paix même
quand l'ego semble se préoccuper du
présent ce n'est pas le présent qu'il
voit il le perçoit de façon totalement
déformés car il regarde à travers les
yeux du passé ou bien et le réduit à un
moyen pour arriver à une fin une fin qui
n'existe jamais que dans le futur
projetée par lui observez votre mental
et vous verrez qu'il fonctionne comme ça
le secret de la libération réside dans
l'instant présent quand vous avez
atteint ce degré d'éveil vous continuez
à vous servir de votre pensée aux
besoins la seule différence c'est que
vous le faites de façon beaucoup plus
efficace et pénétrante qu'avant vous
vous servez de votre mental
principalement pour des questions
d'ordre pratique vous n'êtes plus sous
l'emprise du dialogue intérieur
involontaire et une paix profonde s'est
installée lorsque vous employez le
mental en particulier quand vous devez
trouver une solution créative à quelque
chose vous aussi les toutes les quelques
minutes entre la pensée et le calme
entre le vide mental et le mental le
vide mental c'est la conscience sans la
pensée c'est comment de cette façon
qu'il est possible de penser de manière
créative parce que c'est seulement ainsi
que la pensée acquiert vraiment un
pouvoir lorsqu'elle n'est plus relié aux
très grands royaumes de la conscience la
pensée seul devient stérile un sens et
destructrice
pourrait car tollé nous faisons erreur
quand nous cherchons à nous définir
notre expérience passée ou dans des
projets futurs des éléments qui
permettraient de dire qui nous sommes
ce que nous holmes
c'est très simple
nous sommes
ça
conscience s'accomplit dans la présence
au monde
nous ne cessons pas d'être lorsque nous
plongeons dans l'instant présent
r
c'est le man nous
réellement
man où nous expérimentons lettre
voie de l'être c'est la prise de
conscience que nous ne sommes pas notre
mental
que nous ne sommes pas nos pensées
car aussi longtemps que nous
le monde l'ombre malheureuse de nos
peurs
de nos angoisses de nos regrets
nous regardons la vidéo m
au bar
prendre part
j
du spectacle de la vie
voir la vie comme une évaluation
permanente
com am permanent
cc c'est de voir la vie comme un decroix
l'ama résoudre
quels problèmes avez vous là maintenant
si vous avez un problème dans le présent
vous devriez déjà être entre de
travailler à le résoudre
car penser à un problème sans chercher à
le résoudre ne servira qu'à l'alimenter
et à lui donner davantage de force
en revanche
si vous et qu'il n'y a pas de problème
là maintenant
si l'expert
à présent vous procure un sentiment de
quiétude et de paix profond d'eux
alors c'est que vous avez réussi à
sortir de l'emprise du mental
avait pris conscience
présent aucun pro m
revivre
et que vous
mais la clé de votre libération
de la présence au monde
je vous remercie
[Musique]